we're here at CES unveil where we got a
preview with some of the coolest gadgets
that we're going to see at the Big Show
and that you're going to see in twenty
ten leading the lineup i think is 3d
television one of the reasons is that
well avatar was huge a billion dollars
in sales go figure and a lot of that was
driven by 3d the other thing is that
blu-ray now has a 3d standard so you'll
actually be able to get 3d content for
your television TV manufacturers
including mitsubishi sony samsung and
others are all going to be showing 3d
televisions the question is are you
really going to want to sit with sort of
funky glasses that might cost a hundred
dollars or more on your face to watch 3d
maybe if you're by yourself but I can't
really see you know getting together for
an Olympics party or a Super Bowl party
with a bunch of friends and all of us
are wearing 3d glasses so I don't know
we'll have to see how that technology
improves out
another big category at CES this year is
eBook readers and these are low power
high resolution things that let you read
books and magazines and until the fabled
apple tablet comes along this is the
next best thing to reinventing paper
there are a whole bunch of eBook readers
this year and maybe some of them will
actually even be kind of worth looking
at the third category of things that are
dominating CES this year our netbooks in
every variation and we all know about
netbooks which are super cheap super
light portable computers computer
manufacturers have decided well that's
not enough we're going to make even
lighter ones Lenovo's new skylight is
super light super thin very cute little
red thing based on the Qualcomm ARM
processor built in 3g all kinds of
wireless looks very slick in addition to
that we're going to see a bunch of cool
toys flying objects there are some neat
massage chairs here which I can't wait
to check out and I think there was a
shrimp bar over there somewhere that
might still have a few shrimp left on it
I gotta go check that out